I will Echo and rig a steakhouse staple
here in the valley is opening up a new
location Rocky stop by to give us a
preview
now usually we have Echo and Rick in
studio firing up the stove in the
kitchen but now it is all about their
brand new location here at The District
Green Valley Ranch so Chef Sam
congratulations oh thank you Rocky we're
so excited to be here we can't wait to
open in the community we're giving you a
behind the scenes look as you can see
people are working hard to get it ready
for the grand opening in a few days
actually but let's talk about what's new
here at this location what's the
difference between the two so right now
the difference is definitely going to be
a few things right our cocktail program
totally different I brought in two
superstars local Superstar everything's
local uh Tobin Ellis and Tony abugam and
they designed the bar the carop program
everything about the bar is going to be
really exciting and of course the
butcher concept that's something you
guys are very proud of but it's a little
different here it is yeah that's part of
our concept of the butcher right here
we're going to be doing some dry age
meats here what's more like a little
retail jewelry store right you don't see
a lot of blood and guts you're gonna see
just these diamonds sparkling in the
cake days we got a great head butcher
Howard over there who we brought on you
know in the last few months he's already
getting started it's going to be we're
gonna rock him over here so this is
actually where people can come in and
buy Meats to make at home themselves
absolutely and Howard will cut it for
them or we'll have a grab and go case
like chocolates and sodas but we're
gonna have fillets and chicken breasts
and pork chops instead yeah oh you guys
are making it convenient for us you're
cooking for us and you're giving us our
groceries all right now let's take a
walk because I want to show you the art
in here is really beautiful too and
somebody very special is doing your
columns hand hand-painted he is that's
Jason uh Atienza and he's uh now local
again Local's big for us but he's been
like last five years in Shanghai he's a
very acknowledged artist in the world
and mutual friend we came in here we
talked for a little while we shook hands
and he says I'll do it so he's doing all
my columns for me yeah what does it mean
to you for people coming here to make
sure your new location is the best it
can be helping you oh man I get
goosebumps Rocky I really do every time
I hear that right it's amazing the
community has changed my life right in
in the other restaurant Vegas
communities support us so tremendously
and I'm feeling it here again I mean
like it it's words don't describe it
yeah we appreciate all that you do and
it's okay you can be humble now but you
don't have to be humble about your food
so let's talk about the kitchen because
this is a beautiful open concept here
and I hear this is where the action will
really be happening that people can see
yeah this is our wood fire pit all the
steaks pork chops fresh seafood all wood
and Oak is coming out of here wood oven
we're doing a few new cuts of steaks
that aren't even in Vegas at all right
so we're doing a zabaton which is a cut
that you see around the world but you
don't see it too much in the United
States and there's not a single
restaurant in Vegas that's carrying a
zabuchon right now so Japanese cut one
of my favorites super tender super
flavorful that's exciting you can only
get it here Echo and rig the district
and I want to I want to stop here last
but certainly not least if you have a
little Personal Touch to this location I
do this was like my juxtaposition of
like a dive bar wall right a collage but
it's my collage young Wolfgang pucks you
know
um artists that I love
um movies music bands cars like
everything that's part of my life down
to you know down to presidents right
just things that had an impact on my
life right so well you're having
continuing to have an impact on our
community here in the valley
um and this is obviously a very
instagramable moment also on Instagram
you can find out all the location not
locations but the special announcements
you guys have sure yeah opening day and
if you join our Instagram and our
profile there man we throw out a lot of
Swag that you don't you'll get an email
with something from us and it's exciting
to join our team well congratulations
Chef on the new location Echo and rig at
The District Green Valley Ranch it is
beautiful in here and it hasn't even
opened yet so mark your calendars I'll
send it back to you